good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy Friday if you
think about it it turns out that
revolutions cover a multitude of sins
once every conversation in your country
turns political only the politicians
benefit from it in a normal moment the
people in charge would be in deep
trouble right now the rest of us might
be asking the hard questions about why
things seem to be falling apart at the
most basic level why our streets are
filthy why violent crime is rising when
nothing seems to work we pay a lot to
keep this society functioning all of us
of all parties and suddenly we're not
getting a lot in return for that it's
not a very good deal but in the age of
BLM our leaders don't have to answer for
this they just give speeches about
social justice and they're insulated
from all criticism if you persist in
bothering them about their incompetence
they'll have you arrested for hate
crimes so revolution is the best thing
that ever happened to our political
class you see that with perfect clarity
in New York City just a few months ago
bill de blasio was a national joke not
anymore now de Blasio is his generations
al Sharpton he's a protest leader
fighting in the streets for civil rights
the good news is de Blasio no longer has
even to pretend to run New York City and
he's not his public schools for example
are failing in New York which is the
biggest school system in the country
fewer than half the students are
proficient in English and math that is a
disaster most of all for the students
themselves why is that happening
why are the schools failing city
officials don't want to have that
conversation acknowledging there's a
massive problem might require them to do
something to fix it their donors and the
teachers unions oppose change of any
kind unless of course it's a raise now
leaders in New York don't have to
address this they can ignore their
failing schools instead of helping the
kids to learn the city can just blame
racism and call it a day now let me seem
like a weird strategy kind of a strange
explanation in New York racism because
the school population in New York is
fully 84% non-white so not that many
white kids to blame but that has not
stopped the Chancellor of the school
system he recently issued a statement
pledging his commitment to anti racism
and to quote work every day to undo
these systems of injustice you'll notice
the Chancellor was not more
than that he didn't specify which
systems of injustice he was talking
about or how they work and maybe that's
because the kids with the highest test
scores in New York City are not white
they're Asian Asian students score far
higher than any other ethnic group in
New York City not just higher scores in
math but also higher scores in English
proficiency and that seems odd so many
of these students come from poor
immigrant families where no one at home
speaks English so at first glance these
kids don't seem to have much privilege
so how are they so successful for racism
obviously there's no other possible
explanation for disparate press test
scores we're told that every day but it
must be a very stealthy kind of racism
they're practicing
indeed this is an especially diabolical
strain of racism one that helps
non-white immigrant kids most of all it
is a quote system of injustice that
allows penniless foreigners from faraway
countries to arrive here with no
language skills whatsoever and still
shoot to the top of the academic ratings
obviously ladies and gentlemen what
we're dealing with here is systemic
racism at its most systemic the mayor's
wife is in charge of fixing problems
like this mrs. de Blasio was the city's
systemic racism czar but in the end she
wasn't any more specific about the
problem than the Chancellor of schools
had been she didn't explain how this
kind of diabolical racism actually works
what she did say the one thing she was
absolutely confident about is that white
people are to blame even in 2020 to be a
person of color means to live a parallel
existence with white New Yorkers that
reality needs to be understood beyond
communities of color that truth must
inform the curricula in our schools our
history books the memorials we honor and
even how we perceive one another oh so
the Asian kids are doing better than
anyone else in school therefore we must
tear down statues white people got it
makes sense suddenly this kind of
thinking is everywhere here's a tape
from a meeting of the community
education count
in Manhattan the sad part is these are
some of the people who are supposed to
help educate the children of New York
City who badly need education see how
many references you catch as you watch
this to reading or math and compare them
to the time these people spend attacking
each other for being too white what's me
I want to make how to be a better white
person I would like to know before this
meeting adjourns my nephew on my lap was
hurtful to people and was racist that's
the education council meanwhile the
students of New York City 84% of them
non-white most of them can't read
proficiently what a tragedy but it is
true they did talk about reading for a
second and the tape you just saw right
at the end they'd like you to read
something called white fragility by
Robyn D'Angelo white fragility is not
really a book so we used to call a tract
a screed a diatribe it's the kind of
wild-eyed hate propaganda you push just
before you decide to really start
hurting people
it is preemptive justification for abuse
here's the author explaining her thesis
on NBC I'll never forget asking a group
okay so what if you could just give us
feedback on our inevitable and often
unaware racist assumptions and behaviors
and I'll never forget this black man
raising his hand and saying it would be
revolutionary revolutionary that we
would receive the feedback with grace
reflect and seek to change our behavior
that's how difficult we are
Wow that's how big a holes
we are white people are a-holes and
there you have the accumulated
scholarship of Miss Robyn D'Angelo Robyn
D'Angelo keep in mind is probably the
single most popular figure in American
education right now school districts
around the country have made white
fragility required reading your children
are almost certainly read it or be
taught by people who have read it what
does that mean it means that schools
have been closed for months now so the
revolution underway in classrooms has
been hidden from your view but you're
about to find out the hard way how
they've changed